let's see if we can figure out what four
divided by two-thirds is and like always
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own
well one way to approach it is to
realize that this is the same thing as
four
times the reciprocal of two-thirds so
it'd be four times
three
over two
and what is this going to be equal to
you could pause the video again if if
you're so inspired
well what you need to realize is this is
the same thing 4 could be written as a
fraction as 4 over 1. so 4 over 1 times
3 halves
and we've multiplied fractions before to
do that you just multiply the numerators
4 times 3 is equal to 12 and you
multiply the denominators 1 times 2 is
equal to 2. 12 halves well that's the
same thing as
6. this is the same thing as 12 divided
by 2.
but a key question is why does this make
sense you know i you know i said
dividing by something is the same thing
as multiplying by the reciprocal
and to think about that let's draw four
holes
so
let me draw it in the same red color
so let's say that this is
one hole
right over here this is two holes
this is
three holes
and then this is four holes so i have
four holes there and imagine
splitting it up into groups that are
each two-thirds of a whole
so
actually let me just divide everything
into thirds real fast
so i'm gonna divide everything into
thirds
into thirds
so i'm going to make each group a
different color
so here's one group that is two-thirds
here is another group
that is two-thirds
that is or another section that i could
say that represents two-thirds
here is another section that represents
two-thirds
here is another section
folks let me do that in a different
color here is
here is
another section
that can represent two-thirds if i take
those two blue thirds together that's
two-thirds and then last but not least i
have another two-thirds
so how many sections that are each
two-thirds large do i have
well i have
one
and then these is two and then i have
three and then i have four and then
these two combined make a
make my fifth section that is two-thirds
large and then finally i have six
so i have six i can take four holes and
split it into six equal sections that
are each two thirds of a whole so four
divided into sections that are
two-thirds of a hole you will get six
sections